if you want to build muscle size and
strength but you only have a pair of
really light dumbbells to hand then
never fear the bioneer is here the good
news is that if you only have light
dumbbells there's still a ton you can do
to build strength and performance and in
fact there's a particular technique i've
used with light weights that i credit
for 90 of my own physique and a lot of
my own performance this is something you
can only do with lighter weights or your
own body weight or resistance bands and
so i'm going to talk about it now and i
think it's one of the most overlooked
strategies for building muscle and
improving overall performance to go and
find those turquoise dumbbells you
bought in your 13 and let's start
building some muscle
much better so the main big strategy
that i want to talk about in this video
is using partial range of motion or
continuous time under tension the
intention here being to prevent yourself
from locking out at the top or the
bottom of the movement and thereby to
ensure that you don't get any rest you
don't get any intra set rest so between
each repetition there's no slight pause
and there's no opportunity for your
muscle to get more blood what many
people don't know is that their muscles
actually work like little hearts like
pumps that help to move blood around the
body when you contract a bicep you
basically squeeze the blood out and then
when you relax it it sucks it back in so
when you perform lots and lots of
repetitions without any breaking between
no rest without locking up the joints at
all this creates hypoxia it reduces the
amount of blood that gets to the muscle
and there are some interesting studies
that now demonstrate that this is the
case this has a similar effect to blood
flow restriction training without the
need for straps at the same time this
causes the buildup of metabolites things
like igf-1 and growth hormone in the
muscle which may further stimulate and
encourage hypertrophy and because your
body then responds to the lack of oxygen
and blood supply in the muscle it can
even increase vascularization then you
get a greater blood supply to the muscle
that means better strength endurance
during regular training it also means
faster recovery post training because
your body can deliver more nutrients to
the muscle on top of all that there's
even studies now showing a correlation
between vascularization of a muscle and
myonucleic account that is to say that
your myonuclei increase when you
increase the blood supply this gives you
a greater propensity for protein
synthesis and muscle building with
greater blood supply to the muscle more
metabolic stress more myonuclei we could
expect this to have quite a profound
effect on muscle growth and that's why i
think a lot of bodybuilders intuitively
use this kind of pump training to get
that feeling of being extremely small in
the gym because that then translates to
greater growth outside of it and on top
of all this it can also increase the
activation of fast twitch muscle fibers
the reason for this is that by inducing
hypoxia you cause the slow twitch muscle
fiber to give up much quicker so
basically when you go to move a weight
you will engage motor units depending on
how heavy that weight is and how quickly
you want to use it your body will only
recruit the smallest and slowest muscle
units necessary to conserve energy so
normally if you're just picking up a
spoon that's going to be your slow
twitch muscle fibers however if you lift
something very heavy or want to launch
it really far you'll engage your fast
twitch muscle fibers this is why we
conventionally want heavy weights as
well as to create muscle damage however
when you use a lightweight but go to
high high repetitions without resting at
all then you can fatigue the slow switch
muscle fibers and now your body has no
choice but to switch to the faster
twitch muscle fibers and when you create
hypoxia in the muscle according to
studies even through this kind of pump
training this happens quicker because
your fast twitch muscle fibers don't
need the same oxygen supply as your slow
switch muscle fibers i'm going to use
push-ups as an example because that's
what i do a lot of using this technique
however you can apply this to other
weights to light weights and i'm going
to show you how to do that as well
basically what i'm going to show you is
going to go against everything you've
been told about how to do a push-up and
when you're watching me do it it's going
to look like i say like i'm cheating so
normally you were told to get into
push-up position
and then to lower yourself nice and
slowly so far with your sternum
then move upwards protracting the
scapula at the top there
and carry on
however the way i'm going to recommend
doing the push-up is
keeping your sternum face about an inch
or even more from the floor exploding
straight upwards so that you're almost
doing a plyometric push-up you'd almost
launch up in the air
and then literally just dropping back
down and going again immediately so the
aim here is to get as many repetitions
as you can like so
and then the idea is to pump those out
to failure and that's important because
that's what's going to allow the fast
twitch fiber to take over and give you
that explosiveness and build more muscle
more quickly
this is unfortunately one of the
unintended consequences i see of youtube
in general the homogenization of
exercise you see a few people perform an
exercise in a certain way and telling
you that this is the best way to do it
and other ways aren't as effective and
so then everybody performs exercise in
that way they're afraid to do anything
different because they don't want to be
judged on instagram or on youtube or
even just in the gym as doing it wrong
however there are multiple different
ways to perform the same exercise and
they can provide different results so
locking out at the top of a push-up for
example is really great for developing
scapular control and and slow eccentrics
is great for creating hypertrophy
through muscle tears and building
strength and control and you know your
sticking points in the range of motion
however going fast and explosively like
this clearly has benefits as well and of
course the exact same principle can be
applied to bodyweight rows to pull ups
but also dumbbell curls with a light
weight also shoulder press literally any
movement that's safe to perform with
high repetitions like this and a more
explosive cadence i wouldn't recommend
doing something like an olympic lift
like this or a deadlift however squats
are absolutely fine hindi squats are
fine
lunges are fine you might think this
sounds absurd but if you just give it a
go i think a lot of people are going to
find that incorporating three sets of
100 push-ups at the end of their
workouts maybe a few times a week will
create a lot of growth in the pecs
especially if it's not what you're used
to so yeah just try it there are so many
anecdotal stories of people building
massive muscle using just body weight
but i think that the secret source is
that lack of lockout the continuous time
under tension this is one of the ways i
keep my physique looking kind of
okay-ish for this channel despite
spending an awful lot of time doing
things like mobility training and hand
balancing i just spent 15 to 20 minutes
a few times a week pumping out these
high repetition movements with a
lightish weight and with continuous time
under tension
and i know what you might be thinking
you might be thinking that by not using
full range of motion you're not going to
be developing as much strength because
you're not going all the way down to the
bottom and the top this might be true to
a certain extent but there's actually
mixed evidence it's not as clear-cut as
you think when it comes to the benefits
of full range of motion and how that
applies to different muscle groups it
seems that it actually varies from
muscle group to muscle group and it
seems to have a bigger effect in the
legs in particular but we just don't
know how much range of motion
contributes to strength it seems to in
some cases when you hold an isometric
contraction just hold one position you
actually build strength 15 degrees above
and below that joint angle so if you're
coming almost to the top then chances
are that you're going to be building a
bit of strength above and a bit of
strength below and that might well be
enough and another thing to consider is
that you don't necessarily need strength
all the way through the range of motion
depending on what your goals are when it
comes to vertical jump for instance
studies show that there isn't actually a
huge advantage to squatting below
parallel or too parallel because when
you perform a vertical jump you don't
squat all the way down touch your ass to
the grass and then leap up in the air
you just do a small dip and then launch
back up so in the study it was found
that using dip style squats which don't
even go to parallel could improve the
vertical jump just as much however once
again i'm not saying that you do this
instead of full range of motion i'm
saying you do this as a separate
alternative approach full range of
motion is fantastic for things like
mobility so don't stop doing that just
do this on top of it a technique you can
use to take this even further past
failure is a mechanical drop set i've
talked about this a lot of times the
idea is that you switch immediately from
the movement you're doing to slightly
easier version of the movement it's like
lowering the weight so you can carry on
going
even when you're fatigued and that way
you can exhaust even more fibers than
would otherwise be possible an example
of this would be to do as many push-ups
as you can then to stop and immediately
start doing push-ups on your knees
or for instance you can do as many curls
as you can and then immediately switch
to doing hammer curls
and if you want to be really crazy you
can end with something called burns
which is where you only perform as much
of the range of motion as you're now
able to do so you might perform you know
20 curls then you might do 10 hammer
curls and then you might switch
immediately to
doing just this with your arms to
literally fatigue all of the muscle
fibers don't recommend this until you're
quite experienced because
this really is taxing but
it does a whole lot for growth and for
muscle endurance and yeah once again i
recommend you just try it before you
knock it it might not be for you but it
might work wonders this is the bicep
routine that i always use curls hammer
curls sometimes cheek hammer curls while
i'm swinging and then burns at the end
where i'm just doing that small amount
of movement the push-ups of course will
just be pushing yourself a little bit
bouncing up and down just above the
ground and this works better with our
purposes here than a drop set with
weights because a drop set with weights
requires you to stop training to go and
get the weight and then to carry on
whereas the mechanical drops that you
can switch immediately with absolutely
no pause in between
so an alternative version of this
continuous tension approach which is to
use very slow repetitions a very slow
cadence this is something that pavel
satsulin recommends
this way you don't engage the fast
switch muscle fibers because you're not
sending the right neural drive not
sending the right message to activate
them if the weight is too light and you
use a large motor unit you're gonna like
launch it in the air your body doesn't
have the option to use part of a motor
unit you either engage it and exert that
power or you don't so if you go slow you
simply won't engage those motor units
you'll just fail in a different way and
pavel points out the importance of
training the slow twitch fibers to
failure because slow-twitch fibers do
contribute to your strength you don't
only use flow twitch or fast twitch
fibers use a combination in any scenario
and of course your size as well because
fast twitch fibers might be larger but
slow twitch fibers still contribute some
size it's really hard to fatigue the
slow twitch fibers so if you use really
slow repetitions like three second
eccentric and don't lock out the
movement keep under that tension then
you can train your switch fibers in that
way and just moving really slowly
through a range of motion with light
weight means you change the strength
curve you're not cheating by creating
momentum you have to engage and control
the movement all the way through which
can lead to more strength and of course
light weights can come in very useful
when training smaller muscles and
isolating them or when using positions
where a mechanical disadvantage whether
you're doing something like dumbbell
face pulls for example you want a
lighter weight for something like that
or tricep kickbacks even so yeah when it
comes to treading with weights bigger is
not always better i hope you found this
video useful and interesting let me know
in the comments down below what you use
lighter weights for if you found this
useful then please like it and share it
around that helps me out immensely
particularly sharing with friends or
posting on forums etc there's a huge
amount to boost the channel i want to
take a moment to thank you guys so much
for your continued support in particular
lobbying to get me mentioned on channels
like greg ducett's i really appreciate
it he made a really nice video and i
have you guys to thank for it so yeah i
couldn't be more grateful if you guys
like this kind of training that looks at
alternative approaches to building
strength and performance not just size
not just strength in the big lifts but
different interesting aspects of how you
can use your body then you might enjoy
my ebook and training program super
functional training there's a link to
that description down below i also have
a print book functional training and
beyond which you can get from all good
bookstores including amazon and i'll put
a link to that as well that's a kind of
introduction to the concept of
functional training and why it's so
valuable for athletes but also everybody
else either way thank you again so much
guys and i'll see you next time
bye for now